bonsoir georges estiévenart merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
le bilan exact pour le moment on ne
connaît pas même s'il ya des annonces
des divers ministères de la défense
on sait qui c'est la pire crise entre
erevan et bakou depuis 94
comment est ce que vous expliquez ça
selon vous comment est-ce qu'on en est
arrivé là je crois qu'on en est surtout
arriver là parce que depuis plus de
trente ans on a on a un problème qui non
seulement n'a pas été résolu mais qui
paraît encore aujourd'hui largement
insoluble qui est celui de cette de
cette enclave donc revendiquée par
l'arménie en tout cas à part un
gouvernement local séparatistes qui veut
donc sortir de l'azerbaïdjan c'est une
situation pratiquement explicable messin
et qui a fait justement à l'époque dont
les dans les années 90 jusqu'à 30000
tranquillement un million de déplacés et
cetera pour finalement une petite une
petite enclave parce que c'est une
enclave dans laquelle il y a une
majorité d'arméniens
mais la population totale de cette
enclave ne dépasse pas 150 mille
habitants alors c'est un sujet très très
très complexe et hop nous entende et
internationale effectivement on n'a pas
réussi malgré de multiples résolutions
des nations unies
malgré de multiples tentatives de
médiation vous les avez cité d'ailleurs
dans le reportage
et bien malgré ça on arrive toujours à
la même situation
cependant est ce fait peut être un début
de d'explication avait un début de
journée dans un début de tournoi me
semble-t-il de la situation parce que il
y a un certain déséquilibre est en train
de se creuser actuellement en défaveur
de l'armée justement quel est l'état des
forces en puissance alors l'état de
l'état des forces en puissance
bon je ne saurais pas vous donner ici le
détail des forces armées est ce qu'on
sait très bien c'est que d'un côté
l'azerbaïdjan au cours des dernières
années a considérablement renforcé son
potentiel
elle est il en a les moyens puisque
évidemment ils profitent de la manne
énergétique qui lui permet d'acquérir
assez facilement de nombreux équipements
les militaires c'est plus compliqué pour
l'arménie
l'arménie elle n'a pas une économie
tellement florissante en ce moment et je
crois bien que en arménie ont craint une
déstabilisation par rapport à
l'interview sur ce point de vue là
justement
alors bien entendu vous avez rappelé
tout à l'heure dans les reportages qui
réunit 30 relations entre la russie et
l'arménie
à travers cette étroite relation il y a
eu aussi des fournitures d'armes pour
l'arménie qui ont permis de maintenir
plus ou moins la balance mais à moyen
long terme
on a nettement l'impression que la
déstabilisation est en outre vous avez
parlé de manne énergétique on sait que
l'azerbaïdjan est un important
producteur de pétrole de gaz
cette question d hydro des hydrocarbures
est ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle est
présente dans ce conflit ce qu'il y a
des ressources que chaque camp voudrait
avoir absolument elle est totalement
prévente est la meilleure preuve c'est
le dernier incident en date avant celui
dont nous parlons aujourd'hui c'était
bien celui d'hier c'était le 12 juillet
dernier rappelez-vous 2 juillet 2020 il
y a de nous de nouveaux des escarmouches
entre l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
mais on n'avait pas eu d'aussi
importantes depuis 2016 seulement cette
fois ci au lieu d'avoir
au lieu de ceux de ce2 se placer sur le
problème du haut karabagh les incidents
du mois de juillet se sont déroulés à la
frontière entre l'ex clave de toulouse
qui est une ex classe de 2de
de là verbeek gens par rapport à
l'arménie donc autrement dit ce
conflit-là des mois de juillet il est
éclaté sur la frontière internationale
entre l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
ce qui n'est plus du tout la même chose
que quand il s'agit du haut karabagh
alors donc ça veut dire qu'il y ait une
extension et l'extension des problèmes
et cette extension des problèmes et ne
portent pas par hasard si trait sur
cette région
c'est ce district de tovuz parce que
c'est là que parce qu précisément les
principales ressources énergétiques qui
partent de l'azerbaïdjan qui rejoignent
la turquie et qui vont ensuite vers
l'europe alors et il y en a il y en a
trois qui sont tout à fait cruciaux il
vous avez le pipeline btc
bakou-tbilissi-ceyhan pour le pétrole
vous avez un corridor le corridor gazier
du sud qui ensuite eric tout le tout le
sud européen et vous avez le couloir
ferroviaire dtk bakou tbilissi kars qui
relie en fait l'europe et la chine et
qui est une partie essentielle un
maillon essentiel de la route de la soie
et quelques conséquences au niveau
international de ce conflit quand même
local on sait qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
réactions à l'international on a vu la
turquie la russie la france les états
unis
quelles conséquences alors le le gros
problème que je vois moi pour le moment
fait que les la communauté
internationale ça comporte
sur ce sujet la russie la france
l'europe en général et même les
etats-unis ont appelé ont appelé à une
reprise des négociations d'abord un
cessez-le-feu immédiat et une reprise
des négociations entre les deux
partenaires
et chacun de ces pays est prêt à exercer
son influence pour essayer de favoriser
la reprise de ce dialogue et et disons
la décroissance des hostilités mais là
où il y a un problème un peu plus
sérieux c'est que du côté de la turquie
ce n'est pas nouveau certes il est tout
même la turquie
s'est prononcé très clairement en dix
ans nous nous sommes du côté de
l'azerbaïdjan et nous utiliserons tous
les moyens dont nous disposons c'est
qu'il semble quand même assez allé assez
loin dans le vocabulaire pour faire en
sorte que la cause de la verve et jean
enfin remporté la victoire dans ce bras
de fer
alors nous nous en sommes là mais il ya
quand même
comme vous le voyez des fissures aussi
qui apparaissent dans la communauté
internationale en rapport à ce sujet qui
encore une fois est un sujet là
n'avaient plus difficile à réseau dans
mon avis sur le plan mondial aujourd'hui